من العجز خلال سنوات الماضيه الى الفائق
يعطيك العافيه
حياكم الله جميعا صبحكم الله بالخير
الحمد لله رب العالمين
ما
حدثنا عنه قبل يمكن
اعتقد خمس سنوات
من رحله كانت بداناها ببرنامج التوازن
المالي وكان عند يعني في البدايه كان فيه
تحدي كبير جدا
في مثل هذا الوقت قبل خمس سنوات كان العجز
تقريبا 15%
من الناتج المحلي
اضطرينا خلال هذه مواجهه العبس انه نسحب
اعتقد ما يتجاوز التريليون ريال من
الاحتياطيات
وان نستديم تقريبا 985
تقريبا ترليون ريال من الدين
هذا تحدي كبير وغير مستدان لا يمكن ان
تستمر
[موسيقى]
الى مرحله يكون خدمه الدين ايضا عاليه جدا
ولذلك كان برنامج
وصلنا الى 0 عجز الحمد لله وحققنا فائق
يعني في
مؤتمر الصحفي قبل عده ايام تحدث احد
الصحفيين على
انه الفائز لانه البترول ارتفع
واكرر اقول الحمد لله على البترول
يعني ليس عيبا ان يكون عندك
موارد تستغلها وتستغلها بكفاعها لتحقيق
ونشاهد دول حولنا وفي مختلف دول العالم
عندهم الموارد هذه لا نستطيع استغلالها
الكفاءه اللي تستغلها المملكه وتحقق من
خلفها منتجات لكن منجزات لكن انا اعتقد
الشيء الاساسي هو انه خلال خمس سنوات هذه
مرينا باصلاحات هيكليه كبيره جدا
تحدث عن بعضها بس في النهايه النتيجه
الايرادات كانت تغطي النقديه كانت تغطي
فقط 10% من
من الانفاق تقريبا
في نهايه 21
في نهايه 21 لما اقفلنا الدفاتر
الايرادات غير النفسيه غلطه تقريبا 40%
من الانفاق ماذا يعني هذا يعني هذا انه
اعتمادك على ايراد ياتي من
مصدر متذبذب
خطر جدا
وهو ما ادى الى مساله الحجوزات السابقه
الان وصلنا الى مرحله
انتقل من مرحله برنامج التوازن المالي الى
برنامج استخدام الماليه اللي يخطط على من
سنوات
الى 25
هذا جزء
الجزء الثاني اعتقد مهم جدا صراحه انه
اصبح الانفاق معتمد ايضا على استراتيجيات
وليس فقط على ان الجهه تيجي تطلب من وزاره
الماليه
يتفق عليها تعتمد من مركز الحكومه من تم
يسير
الاستراتيجيه كتمويل الاستراتيجيه مع
الجاهليه
يعني هناك الكثير الحديث يعني شكرا محمد
طيب
دائما ما عليك كنت تحدث عن بنود لهذه
الميزانيه
حدث هذه المره عن ركائز لهذه الميزانيه
المواطن عنصر اساسي تعتمد عليه المملكه في
ما يحدث من تطوير تمكين المراه
تعزيز جوده الحياه الى اي مدى يضل توجيهات
القياده
وتوجيهات التي تصلكم مباشره سيدي خادم
الحرمين الشريفين ولي العهد
الرئيسي يمكن شاهدنا سمعنا تصريح سمو ولي
العهد همم بعد اعلان الميزانيه كان واضح
في هذا الموضوع
انا بالنسبه لي اقول لك بشكل واضح انا لا
افرق بين عمل
لصالح استراتيجيه الحكومه
استراتيجيه القطاعيه والاستراتيجيه
مناطقيه والعمل لمصلحه المواد اذا عملت
مصلحه الدوله
اللي حصل خلال السنوات الماضيه كان في
تركيز كبير جدا على تحسين الخدمات
المواطنين رفع كفاءه الخدمات المقدمه
الاستفاده من كل الريال ينفق في الميزانيه
اللي رفع مستوى الخدمات رفع العائد من هذا
الرجال
خلال سنه 22 كان في اهتمام كبير جدا في ظل
التقلبات الكبيره جدا وما يحصل من
جائعه كوفيت وما بعدها والنتائج اللي
ترتبت عليها ومن ثم الوضع السياسي المتوتر
جدا في اوروبا بين روسيا واوكرانيا من نقص
في
الامدادات وتعطل بعض سلاسل الانداد كان في
حرز كبير جدا من الحكومه على اتخاذ خطوات
السباقيه
وسنتحدث عن ممكن شغلتين او ثلاثه مهمه
الاولى انه المملكه من عام 21
وبسبب
التحليلات الاستوائيه سواء من الزملاء في
زهره الاقتصاد او من جهه اخرى حتى في مركز
الحكومه
استشرفت انه الدعم الكبير الذي قدمته عدد
من الدول